[موسيقى]
على أفضل طفل للعميل مجرد عادي
أعطى صندوق بسيط لكمة
أو دقة عالية
في كاري متوسط ​​الدهون أو الطائرة مع
تسأله الطبول عن الطالب الذي يذاكر كثيرا في المنطقة
هذه
يجب تسريع المرض
السفن
السفينة هناك جراد البحر كبير
التي تم تعليقها في دائرة هنا
طبق الحل التالي المخفي
جيل علاوة على
إذا كان العميل لا يملك المال لمثل هذا
حاوية مدفع
عرض الآلات الميكانيكية كاملة
مشاهدة من هنا وعرض المطلوب
بانورامية مع وظيفة شاشة تعمل باللمس
شاشة تعمل باللمس ممكن
المعلومات المنفذة الخوارزمية
الدعم الفكري
الذكاء الذي يفرغ الطيار
فيما يلي العمليات الروتينية التي يمكن القيام بها
التركيز على المهام الأساسية و
سآخذ
الوزن ضربة صغيرة جدا هنا ولدت
مكانين لا تبيد بشكل مريب
ما يسمى العمارة المفتوحة
نفذت مما يسمح
جزء الرأس إما بدون طيار أو
طائرة ذات مقعدين
[موسيقى]